أنت بخير
[موسيقى]
، هل أعجبك
الاحتفال أكثر من ذلك ،
نعم ، لقد حصلت على ابتسامة كبيرة على وجهك
[موسيقى
] لقد اشتهرت
لقد كنت في كل مكان خلال الـ 24 ساعة الماضية
وأنت خمسة أشهر الآن
أعلم أنني كنت في كل مكان لديك
[موسيقى] ،
هل كنت تعتقد أنني سأفعل ذلك أم
لا أعتقد أنك نسيت لا ، لم
أنس
[الموسيقى]
وبعد ذلك إذا فعلت ذلك ، فسأفعل ذلك من أجلكم
جميعًا  حسنًا ، لكني لا أستطيع أن أفعل الدودة ،
حتى أنني لا أفعل ذلك ، فقد أتعرض للإصابة ،
تريد أن تفعل هذا ، حسنًا ،
سأفعل ذلك من أجلك ، أعدك ولكن
تذكر أنني حصلت على نتيجة بالرغم من ذلك في
المرة القادمة  في المرة القادمة في المدرسة ، حسنًا
، سأفعل ذلك من
أجلك ، كان يجب أن تتناول وجبة خفيفة في حقيبتي
وكان من الممكن أن نكون هنا
معنا ، نعم
[تصفيق]